all right thank you for coming for my
talk uh it's great to be here it's my
first time at the pycon pie data
um and it's been exciting to see all of
the cool stuff that's going on and today
i wanted to share a little bit about
what we're trying to do in um in
academia
in my group um i should say that i'm
giving this talk on behalf of
evangelists who couldn't be here today
and so
he's say
why is this not showing
he said the guy to the right here
together with the rest of the team laura
eddo and gemma we're maintaining the the
core imaging
library or
cil all right so what is the cil
it's an
open source python library for solving
inverse problems so imaging type inverse
problems
and in particular we have a special
emphasis on tomography applications so
ct scan type
setups with kind of challenging data
sets so so if you can't get away with
the standard method if you have
poor data low count data
some some non-standard setup in
incomplete data or otherwise a
challenging setup this is the kind of
case where we're looking at it's it's
highly flexible modular offers a number
of different tools for for doing a ct
and other kinds of imaging
and in particular we have a we call it a
near-math specification and solution of
optimization problems
as part of this package um
we think it's it's quite simple to get
started yet powerful enough to actually
handle large um
large data sets real real applications
it's funded by a uk initiative called
the ccpi and it's released under an
apache v2 license and it's all on github
so what i'll cover today i'll be talking
a little bit about direct and inverse
problems
and i'll have a few demos and if you're
interested you can go
and
type along for the uh
the first one at least you can go to
this link and launch the binder should
be up and running
then i'll talk about the inverse
problems and how we solve them and then
the rest of the demo
move on to talk about ct imaging a bit
more in particular and then talk about
i have another demo
and finish with showing some of the the
cases we've been working on where we've
been able to improve the the imaging
all right so let's get started
so first of all what is an inverse
problem and in in a kind of general
context you can think of
uh we're interested in determining some
parameters some object this would
typically be an image but we don't have
access to it so what we do
um basically this image gives rise to
some data some measurements and so those
are the data we can obtain those
and the direct problem is is how the
object is mapped to the data the inverse
problem is then going the other way so
how do we from the measured data go back
and obtain the quantity we're interested
in
and we typically write it as this kind
of
mapping so we have an operator here a
forward or a direct operator that maps
the the image to the to the data
and i've got a couple of examples here
so one case is this image
d blurring so so the the direct problem
would be assume we know
an underlying kind of sharp image that's
what we want to estimate
um but we only observe the result of the
direct problem namely the blurred image
over here
and our task is then to
solve the inverse problem of recovering
the sharp image from the
just the observed blurred image
another case could be
images where parts are missing so this
is sometimes called in painting or
filling in the blanks of this image so
this is the kind of true image we don't
have access to
i guess you don't see my my pointer here
but to the left
and what we observe is the result of the
direct problem namely the
the corrupted image to the right with
some parts
missing and some noise also and we want
to solve the inverse problem of going
back and
obtaining the image over here
and the last case i've got today is a ct
emitting so computer tomography and here
we have some
some some object here i have a
two-dimensional image what we do is we
we rotate it and we acquire x-ray
projections of this
image
and each
projection here looks like this maybe
and we stack them all together into
what's called a cyanogram over here this
is our measured data and then again we
want to solve the inverse problem of
going back and recovering the image
um
so that's what it looks like um and i'm
going to switch to the first part of the
demo
right here hoping that it still works
did when i was just testing right now so
we'll be looking at i think i need to
let's see
switch this off
and go
here
all right
right so we will be looking at a case of
d blurring so recovering a sharp image
from a
an observed
unsharp image so from from our library
from sil we import a number of different
tools we need
and that's the starting point
we can we can set up some some different
test images some some boat and camera
some of those kind of usual test images
we use in
this field
one of them is a resolution chart
and we see what we get is something
two-dimensional of the shape 256 by 256
pixels
in in the x and y dimensions we set up a
a display function that we can use
throughout to get consistent plots and
then show our image so this is what the
kind of
true image that we wouldn't have access
to looks like
um okay
so so this is an image we have a special
data type for that we call it image data
and it kind of contains some additional
information about the size and how big
are the pixels and and so on so we hold
that in our image data class here
and in particular we see we have
something we call the geometry which is
where all this this extra information is
is stored where is it located and how
big is everything
okay
so our setup is the following so so
assume we knew the image
then we will be mapping that through an
operator here this will be our blurring
operator and then we'll be adding some
some noise to that so that's some
gaussian noise in this case and then
this is what we observed this is our
data
um in this particular case for the d
blurring what we do is we apply some
point spread function
and this is kind of a blurring kernel it
looks like this
we kind of move that across the whole of
the image and that's what's what will
generate
our blurred our blurred data
in order to do that in in sil we need to
set up this um
this a operator here
and so we have an operator class for
that and we we give it the the point
spread function and it also needs to
know about the geometry of the image
we're looking at so that will be our a
here
then we apply it so we say basically do
the direct
problem of the
underlying true image which will give us
our blurred image so we get it here and
we see it's it's been blurred
and on top of that to make things a
little bit more difficult maybe we
didn't observe a clean image maybe we
had some noise
added to that that's typically the case
and we can simulate that by by this
gaussian function here we take the
blurred image and we
we generate some some random gaussian
noise and apply it here
okay so this was basically the
direct part we've started from a true
image that is what we want to
determine in the end and so we kind of
forget about that and just work from the
from the observed blurred and noisy data
here
okay i'll switch back to the
presentation now
um
right here
so how do we do that um
how do we solve such an inverse problem
so basically it's kind of a linear
problem typically we we've got here this
is our setup it can be non-linear
as well but in this case it's a linear
problem so it's basically a matrix
a matrix vector equation here
but the problem is
there might not always be a solution or
you might have so much noise that you
can't just do a simple
um kind of matrix vector solution
here and we might have no solution it
might not be stable there can be tons of
different problems so we call this an
ill post problem and we'll see some of
the difficulties in solving that in a
minute
um so this ill-positiveness we have like
various parts that are difficult we have
the the errors
maybe our model is not perfect
of a perfect description of what
happened in reality and maybe we also
have noise as i showed the gaussian
noise
and the data
and what we do so we move from from this
problem here and say we probably can't
solve this problem exactly also we have
some some noise there so what we do
instead is we set up some optimization
problem
and this optimization problem um we want
to solve and the solution will be our
best
image this will be our reconstructed
image so we have two parts normally one
has to do with fitting to the data so
this is kind of a regression term
typically we take that as a least
squares fitting term
uh which is quite common in other
settings as well and then we need to
choose this regularizer which some of
you may also be familiar with whereas
it's some kind of penalty that that puts
a large value on images that are
undesirable maybe are noisy or maybe
have other artifacts and so we want to
minimize the sum of these two to both
get an image that agrees nicely with the
data and also has a low penalty in terms
of this this regularizer
so that's the idea
um so until we have different
ingredients to to handle all of this
and if we start by looking at the the a
part here that is our model we talked
about that already so we had the cases
of the blurring operator as we saw we we
get an
and a blurred image
the other one where you could
mask out some some pixels that you you
don't have access to and you want to
kind of fill fill those pixels in
and we have the ct case as well where we
measure something like this lots of
projections of of this or line integrals
of this image and then we want to to to
solve that so that's what our
a our operators do
and next one we have this fidelity term
as i said this is kind of a data fitting
term
and depending on what kind of noise we
observe on our data different systems
will have different noise
we need to use different
ways to measure this different data
fidelity so the simplest case if we have
simple gaussian noise you can derive
it's kind of like a map estimate uh
maximum a posteriori estimate in a
bayesian context if you like but it's
it's just this these squares um
regression or fitting term
and still we call that an l2 norm
squared
you can also have other kinds of noise i
think maybe it doesn't show so clearly
here but if you that your noise is
of the salt and pepper type so basically
black and white pixels
that are added
to your image you need to use what's
called a one norm instead so measure
things in a different way due to the
noise characteristics
you can also have
for song noise and in that case you need
to use what's called the kl distance the
culprit libra um divergence here in all
of these and more are offered by by
still so you can kind of plug and play
try different different um fidelities
out
and we can also try different
regularizers and that's what the demo
will will do in a minute
um so i won't show examples of that here
and the last kind of component we need
is once we have specified everything we
we end up having an optimization problem
so this optimization problem we need to
solve that
and depending on what kind of
optimization problem we've set up we d
we do need to use a a
well-suited algorithm to solve that so
some pro some problems have are
differentiable some problems have other
structure and depending on all of that
we need to pick a
a suitable algorithm and this is what
still provides a number of different
algorithms so there's some gradient
descent algorithms and we're
where
we have one called
fista which i'll be demonstrating in the
demo and other ones that are suitable in
in various cases i won't go into the
details of that just say that we'll be
using the
the uh the fist algorithm in in this
demo here
okay
so that's the second part of this demo
i'll jump right into that
so this was if you recall this was our
um blurred and noisy image and this is
now
all we've got we forget about the the
true image and now we want to try and
recover that and so as we discussed we
set up this kind of optimization problem
so so we choose since we we know we
added gaussian noise we picked this
least squares simple term here
and then we have a look at trying out
different regularizes to try and help us
recover the image actually the first
thing we'll try is to ignore the
regularize and just say let's try just
an and find the image that fits the data
the best
um so until we can we we can specify
these kind of mathematical objects this
function here we we have
a least squares
function object so we specify the the a
part and the the the data here we see
it's this kind of least squares function
object and this is actually the cost
function or the objective function that
we want to minimize
and so what we can do is we can we can
for example look at what's the value of
this function if we give it some some
image so we could give it a blank
image just full of zeros and we see this
is the cost or the objective for that
particular image 51 000 something
and i don't know if that's big or small
but we could for example also give it
the image of all ones
and see what that looks like apparently
that has a much smaller value so this is
is in in this setting it's a better
image it has a lower value here so what
we want to do is find the image that
causes this f to be the the smallest and
this is what we need
an algorithm for
so we as i said we use the fist
algorithm we need to specify it's an
iterative algorithm so we start
at this initial image the zero image
here we specify the cost function to
minimize how many iterations to run
and also how often to display
information to the to the user on the
screen so we set that up and then we can
run it we say okay maybe start by
running ten iterations
and we see it runs and we show the
solution and and this is this is now
what it looks like and see okay we we
see some of the noise has has gone or
has been actually been smeared out a
little bit more
and it's still kind of blurry so okay
maybe maybe we need to run some more
iterations uh so we do that
and the algorithm is just kind of paused
we can continue from where we left off
and run another
90 iterations and so the algorithm tells
us a few things how long it took for
each iteration and and how our objective
is decaying we see it's still changing
quite a bit so probably we haven't
converged uh to the minimizer yet
the image
yeah it just keeps getting noisier it
seems it may be a bit sharper i don't
know but it's for sure a lot noisier
and so it's not great and actually what
will happen if you keep iterating we see
we will be reducing the objective so we
are we are solving the optimization
problem as we intended but we just keep
getting more noise and this is really
the problem with with these kind of ill
post inverse problems the more noise
you've got and then
with this with these kind of operators
the noise will just come in and kill you
like this so basically
we need to do something else and this is
where regularization comes in so so
we'll try different regularizers to kind
of try and help us deal with this noise
the first thing we'll try
is what's called tick enough
regularization so we'll add a penalty
term like this so it's a squared two
norm
so we set up another function object uh
to do that and the fist algorithm has
two functions you can give it and and it
tries to minimize the sum of these two
so it's the same cold as before
just we have now this uh this
regularizer added so we set up the
algorithm everything is like before just
with the g here and we run it and see
what happens
and it appears to converge now it's not
making any progress after 100 iterations
and this is the image we get um so i'm
not sure
but it seems that the noise is reduced
but it's still very blurry still kind of
blurry and this is because thick enough
is a kind of smoothing regularized so
it's like a smoothing filter you will
get rid of the noise but you won't get
any sharp edges
so it might be all right depending on
what you need to do with the image but
it's not really great
we'll try another one we'll try a one
norm regularization which is uh
where you you basically put a penalty on
the
sum of the absolute value of your pixel
and this is a kind of a sparsity
enforcing prior so we set up everything
like before
and replace it just with this g term
instead and we run and we see
okay it appears to converge also it's
not making any more progress the values
are constant here
and this is what we get
so
not great either it's okay maybe it's a
little bit sharper but still super noisy
um so it's it's it's maybe not the best
either
some cases it might be great depending
on if you have a very sparse image this
might be a really good
regularizer the last one we'll try is
called total variation regularization
and what this does is it tries to
enforce sparsity on the gradient image
so so that's kind of like
trying to enforce a piecewise flat image
so the regions of constant
value and then just some jumps where you
have edges so it's kind of an edge
preserving
a regularizer so we do this
and and still offers the total variation
function here we set it up in the same
way
this takes a little bit longer to run
but the principle is the same
we've just replaced the g here
everything else is the same as before
we're running 200 iterations here
and we see that the objective is
decaying okay it's not decaying much
more so maybe it's it's close to
converged now it will just run a few
more iterations
and what we'll see in a minute when it
when it's done
we'll see that it's actually reduced the
noise quite a lot
and at least for these large features
the edges are nicely
recovered
as you move to the smaller features
it's really difficult for tv to to
distinguish what's noise and what's a
feature so it will tend to kind of blur
things together
so so for this image it's a challenging
one because you have these small
features but if you had just big
regions tv would be would be a really
great prior and so it's just to say that
depending on what what your image
looks like you do need to use different
different regularizes we can look at at
all of the different images compare here
at the end so this was the kind of
underlying secret
on blood image and here's the blurred
one and here's when we solve it without
a regularized it just completely noise
and depending on our choice of of prior
or
regularizer we see we can get something
smooth or something
a bit sharper but still very noisy or we
can get this kind of
piecewise constant which does struggle a
little bit with the small features
okay
so for the next part
um by the way i think questions are
being added to slido we'll take them at
the end
um
right so
for the next case so this will be ct
imaging so computed tomography so once
again we have an image
in the medical setting it would be a
patient in a ct scanner and you spin as
an x-ray source and a detector round and
acquire x-ray images all around
in material science where i work we
normally have it the other way so we
have a fixed x-ray source and a detector
and we have a sample that we rotate on a
rotation stage and acquire these
projections so it might look something
like this
up to the
top left we have a setup with an x-ray
source to the left and the rotation
stage in the middle and a detector to
the right
and then we measure
maybe a couple of thousand projection
images and then the task is to put all
of those two-dimensional images together
and and determine this three-dimensional
reconstructed volume here we scanned a
walnut and you could see nicely in
different cross sections there's a
vertical one and a horizontal one all of
the features inside the the wall nut
and with still
what this would look like you'd read it
in and you'd apply some pre-processing
steps and we have tools to
look at the data and and see what kind
of scan geometry we're using
and then we have a
kind of the standard reconstruction
methods people use all the time is
called filtered back projection so we
have that and this would do this and
then we could show show the image so we
would show these couple slices here
and this is kind of the
the simplest workflow and still here's
an overview of the module we offer
some of these tools to the left are very
ct imaging specific so readers for
different
ct instruments small lab instruments and
big synchrotron facility
data sets
different kind of core data structures
and pre-processing tools and then in the
fifth column this optimization module
which i've been talking about with with
the algorithms and the different
functions to allow us to specify
optimization problems and so on
also we provide interfaces uh the
plugins to the far right to some gpu
accelerated toolboxes to do some of the
heavy lifting for us one is called astro
one it's all called called tcr and i
added a reference there at the bottom
for the for the uh the software
okay so i have another demo
which will be
over here
oh i think i need to
go let's see
switch this off
here
so the first demo was was kind of a
introductory to kind of show uh kind of
a
demonstration of some of the tools and
this this is intended to be more
advanced and more like this is how you
can also work with a real real data set
and deal with some of the non-standard
things you have to for for this
particular data set so it's a so-called
laminography setup
it means it's
it's it's a little bit technical but
normally we would rotate about sort of
an and
like this upright axis here uh
for for for flat samples that are
difficult to image in this conventional
geometry we typically tilt the rotation
axis and and rotate about a tilted axis
and then we can actually handle that in
in still here
and so what we do is we read in
we we specify basically the geometry
where is everything where is the x-ray
source where is the object how is
everything tilted and where are
where are everything basically and so
it's it's just setting up the geometry
of the setup and we we hold that in this
kind of
cell acquisition geometry object where
you see we specify it's a cone and which
angles and where's the detector panel
and and so on
and this is what we display and we see
it looks like this so here's the
detector and here's the reconstruction
volume we'll be we'll be solving for in
a minute
the data are provided as a stack of tiff
files and we have a tif stack reader
here we crop some of the values away and
we only read part of the data to be a
little bit faster
so only every seventh projection and
crop it a bit so we can specify
settings like that and set up the
geometry to fit that
um
so here is where we we do the reading in
and we end up getting this this
acquisition data set which we can then
display in different ways here we're
using our interactive slicer tool
um i don't know if if it works now you
can you can kind of
look at the different projections and
and see what this
this um it's a sample let me just
show you i think i have here's the paper
where we did it it's a test sample we
build of lego bricks to have a kind of
nice and simple uh
test image to look at so we have these
different layers of lego blocks that
we've put together and put in this
scanner over here
okay and this is what one projection
looked like and you can you can look at
a different as you rotate different
orientations you see you kind of
see all of the edges and the structures
of the the data set
so there are some stripes here this is
this is coming from the detector which
has some imperfections we need to
compensate for that by reading in what's
called dark and flat fields and this is
this is we do this we do here and
and do a normalization of the data set
and the details don't really matter it's
just to say we we kind of handle all the
pre-processing steps after that all the
stripes are gone
and the last thing we need to do is
convert from from the measured data
which is in in what's called a
transmission domain to an absorption
domain which is essentially taking the
negative log
of the data this is kind of the physical
model and it ends up looking like
like this
so this would be the the data set as
it's when it's ready for for
reconstruction
uh for solving the inverse problem
um okay
so let's see
uh i'm just gonna skip that so so we'll
start by doing kind of the conventional
type filter back projection
reconstruction
a variant called fdk here
and
so we we set up everything to do that we
do need to do some some reordering of
the data here because we're using this
toolbox which needs data to go in a
special ordering so we do that first
um
then we
set up the volume for us to to
reconstruct onto and and then we apply
the reconstruction algorithm and this is
what
is a little bit difficult to see here
i think i changed the display was it in
this one maybe
anyway so you're meant to see like a
kind of faint reconstruction kind of
dark gray
reconstruction
this is a kind of
it's a fiducial marker so it's a marker
we put in there high contrast to to help
us align the images
um
we can do some further cropping and so
on
to make it a bit smaller so let me just
get further down here
to to um okay so we've reconstructed a
three-dimensional volume now here i
change the contrast so you can see it a
little bit better so you see
in the kind of the flat
direction you see the
the the lego structure here it's not
completely aligned that's why it looks a
little bit different
and here you see some of the other
layers
if you look at a
a
the vertical cross section instead and i
think it's not too clear here but you'll
see you have these kind of
streaks or blurred bits coming from the
top and bottom of all of the features
here and this has to do with with this
tilted geometry so the question here was
how do we deal with that can we somehow
compensate for that
through use of regular rises and and
we try different things basically we try
the same methods i showed you for the
blurring case and and the nice thing is
that once we've set up the operator and
and
we can specify the optimization problem
for this 3d
ct scan in the completely same way as we
had for the deep blurring case and so
what we do is we set up an operator just
like we had the blurring operator before
we now have the the model for for how
the projections arise from the
from the image and we set up again this
least squares
and try just running a least square so
no regularization and and we run it
again with the fista just like before
and we see we we can reduce the the cost
function here quite a bit and this is
what the reconstructed image looks like
um
we didn't add any regularization yet and
actually this
makes sense we see we still have these
kind of kind of
diagonal stripes or blurred bits down
here so here what we'll do is we'll try
the the tv regularization again remember
we saw it was working quite well to help
us preserve edges at least of of kind of
large features so we'll do that again
here see if that's uh
helpful here we use a faster version of
the one we had before which uses the gpu
to accelerate computations but otherwise
it does the same thing so we set up this
this is what we call g before this is
our tv function and then again we set up
the the fist algorithm with the
different components the initial value
to start from the least squares
the tv
penalty term and how many iterations to
run and so on
and we see we reduce the objective quite
a bit and it's kind of slowing down here
so it's not quite converged but it's
it's getting close
and this is what the the images look
like um
and in particular if you look in this
vertical dimension here you see that we
now have much more well-defined edges
here before we had these these diagonal
streaks or stripes
and some blur around and that's
completely gone now so so the tv
regularizer helped us
to
to compensate for this uh for the for
the
um
challenging data set here
and in the end we can compare all of the
different ones we had the standard
method over here
with the with the stripes here and the
least squares without regularizer
here and the tv here to the right and
again we see that we are we are
compensating for for the
for the problems and getting getting
much sharper edges here
okay
so
let me
move on
to
show a few more case studies we've done
i think i need to switch this here
so so in particular we're interested in
cases where we have um another dimension
so the simplest case perhaps is if you
have an image that's a color image
and you have
three channels red green and blue
and basically you have kind of a gray
image in each of these channels with
slightly different values and so
together they form this this color image
so up until now i've only talked about
applying a regularizer kind of within
the image but having these three this
extra dimension we can also look at
enforcing regularity across these
channels
and so sil allows us to to do different
things
here
for example we have a case where this is
the in painting case and so we start
from this corrupted image with parts
missing and noise added and then we try
different methods we try a variant of tv
that i showed you before this is called
tgv
and it's a little bit better for for
when you have a smooth image
and i think you can't maybe see so much
difference between the two but at least
you see we're able to fill in the blanks
and get a nice recovered image here we
use a another algorithm the
pdhg algorithm which is an alternative
to to vista if that's a little bit more
flexible
and the details are in the paper at the
bottom there
we're also also interested in
time resolved imaging so studying
components as some as they change over
time maybe
you can have some process happening and
you want to study that over time
this is a little bit difficult normally
because it takes maybe one hour to
acquire one data set which means
it's difficult to get any any good time
resolution right a lot of stuff can
happen while you acquire that one data
set so what we're trying to do is say
okay we let's
acquire the data a lot faster so maybe
we acquire not a couple of hundred or a
couple of thousand projections but just
uh just 18 projections and if we use the
normal reconstruction method we see we
get lots of streaks and lots of noise
and we can't really see the features of
what we're looking for here
we we put together a new regularizer in
sil which we call the directional total
variation regularizer
and from the same data set we're able to
get this kind of reconstructions here
where we see the features a lot better
and this
this um
this does uh
regularization
trying to
use some edge structures and propagate
them across the channels basically so
it's an example of how we we use more
information that than is just in in one
image and this you can't do with the
kind of conventional method
another case is where we have
an energy
discriminating detector so normally
the photons or neutrons or whatever
you're measuring with
the energy is not recorded by the
detector but we have new detectors
coming out now where we can actually
measure precisely the energy
of different um
different photons
and this is nice because we have
different responses at different
energies
um
so if we use we have a data set here
acquired at a neutron facility in the uk
and if we just look at we have about 3
000 different energy channels and if we
just look at the the data for one such
energy channel we have very few photons
so very noisy data and we get this kind
of reconstruction up here which is which
is very noisy and you basically can't
tell these big
cylinders apart here
um we looked at a couple of different
new regular
regularizes one is called total nuclear
variation and one is called tv tgv
this is where we do tv kind of in the
spatial dimension and and this other
thing tgv across the channels and we see
we're able to get much sharper
cylinders and identify the materials um
a lot better across all of the all of
the channels here
we have also worked with people who are
not doing x-ray imaging but um
pet
and mr imaging and which is a little bit
different and here you also have some
motion that you need to estimate along
the way
and we're able to formulate a
reconstruction problem in still that
takes this motion into account and go
from this kind of
uncompensated image to the left here
to a it's a little bit over smoothed i
think but but but the edges are a lot
better preserved and the noise is
reduced a lot over here
and another case where we have a feature
that with the normal reconstruction
method was very blurry and we see we're
able to get the the edges sharper not
completely sharp because the resolution
is not great but you can see there's a
feature here that's not
visible the same extent over here
okay
so
we run a number of different
activities we have some training events
people from the community are
uh
participating here we this was the only
in-person activity we ran before code
and we've run online sessions we have
another one coming up
and
okay what happened here
um so there's a sign up link if you're
interested there
and other than that i'll just summarize
here so we have
still is an open source python library
for solving inverse problems
specifically for imaging type problems
and in particular we have worked a lot
with challenging ct image data sets so
very noisy low count
data
time resolved and non-standard imaging
setups and and multi-channel type time
images
and it's highly flexible as you can see
we can kind of put together different
regularizers different different
data fidelities and and use different
algorithms to solve the problem we have
an uh close to math near math
specification like how
the code looks almost like the math
which helps specify these optimization
problems normally you'd need hundreds of
lines of code maybe to set that up
and hopefully
people will find it simple to get
started and still
expressive enough to actually and
powerful enough to to to solve big real
problems
there's the website and we have
documentation and different repositories
we've started the discord and
and you're welcome to to contact me at
the uh
email address there
thanks very much
so thanks jacob really wonderful
presentation so i'm gonna now repeat
some questions from this slido
first one is you often don't know what
kind of noise you're dealing with often
also different kinds of noise overlaying
how do you determine the regularizer
yes that's a that's a really good
question and i think you can take you
can take different approaches then you
can you can either just sort of say okay
i don't know what it is and try
different
different combinations of of the tools
we provide and see which one kind of
empirically gives you the best
reconstruction
um or you can try and
and
investigate your noise so look at some
background regions where you have just
air where you have kind of just the
noise signal and try and determine what
kind of noise is there and then based on
that choose your
choose your your data fidelity and a
suitable regularizer
so it's like basically just trial and
error and based on your experience
there is there is some trial and error
aspect to it
but also you can you can try and see if
you can actually determine
from the data what kind of what kind of
noise type it is
second questions
is there anything in cil to facilitate
optimize the choice of regularization
parameter or is it or
i think it's the same question right
it's uh i think it's a related question
and it's it's a really good one and it's
something we'd like to put in there so
so we have
and i didn't talk so much about that
there's this regularization parameter
that governs the trade-off between how
much emphasis do you put on fitting the
data and how much emphasis do you put on
your your penalty term and this is a
parameter you do need to choose at the
moment we don't offer any tools to to
determine the best one um so so the
typical thing people do is they do a
search or a sweep and and pick the best
one there are tools in in the literature
but we we haven't seen any of these
tools are kind of robust enough to to to
put out there
but but if there are some ideas i'm
curious to hear about um what that could
be
which are the most important libraries
under the hood of cl
so i would say
so so
these data sets especially the micro ct
data sets i showed the laminography one
is
it's a couple of gigabytes so it's quite
big data sets reasonably big um
and and there's a lot of heavy lifting
in computing the
basically solving the direct problem and
what's called the adjoint problem
also
and to do that we need to use
gpu acceleration and we use
the astra toolbox which is another open
source tool and the another one is
called tcre and we provide a unified
interface so you can choose
either basically so i think those are
two
important packages to mention that we we
rely on
great
regularizer seems to encode knowledge of
the domain and setup is there any
structured way to encode that knowledge
or is it just intuition and trying them
out
can you repeat that please a regularizer
seems to encode knowledge of the domain
and send up
is there any structured way to encode
that knowledge or is it just intuition
and trying them out
i mean there's there's some
uh
i think there's a lot of experience that
go goes into that but but there is some
theory behind it like for example this
one norm
uh
you can you can show theoretically that
it's it's a
it's a sparsity enforcing prior so it
will tend to push a lot of values all
the way down to zero
um and and preserve only a few values um
and if you know you have a sparse image
so this could be kind of a foam
structure where there's a lot of air and
just a few pixels that are
non-zero you you would expect that kind
of prior that kind of regularizer to be
suitable for for this kind of case so i
think it's it's a bit of both it's a mix
of
of theoretical expectations and and also
some some trial and error and experience
what is the main benefit of the noise
reductions is it true to say that deep
learning models will learn to remove
noise by themselves
so so there's a lot of work on deep
learning
also coming into inverse problems at the
moment
and
and
many cases are showing that deep
learning
type reconstruction methods can
substantially reduce the noise and and
help
solve some of the same problems
sometimes
better than what we can do with these
kind of methods
and but oftentimes the challenge is
getting training data oftentimes we scan
just one thing and the next thing that
comes in looks completely different so
obtaining good training data is is not
so straightforward here
so it's the data that matters how the
model is performed right
in the end i think for if you were to
set up a deep learning model it relies a
lot on on the training data you would
you would feed it with
um
that's kind of the thing okay
i think the time is almost up so
i think we can take one questions from
here so if anyone have any questions
ask the mic
thank you
maybe as a follow-up to the last
question on using deep learning couldn't
your tool be used to generate good
synthetic data for those training
cases
like for example adding all these
different kinds of noise
so so so the question is can you
create synthetic training data and and
develop your deep learning method yes
this this this is this is a an approach
people take with something some some
success
um but again depending on on the setup
and for example this this tilted case
where you have
another setup you you probably need to
do
training data that specifically for that
case
and and there will be
parts of um
what you say um
well the the uh
there's a discrepancy between what you
can do with simulated data and and the
real data you measure
and it's not completely clear if it's
enough to to to do to base it on
simulate the data but it's something
that people are looking into
all right thank you
all right i think the time is almost up
so
let's give it up for jacob again
thank you